la poesia nel mondo negli ultimi anni ha
assunto nuove forme questa è una di
quelle forme bene a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti e questo video sono fa vige il
gioco di oggi ragazzi si chiama hunt
bassa d'oro che non ha musica di
sottofondo perché perché questo
bellissimo menù non ha la musica
spiegami la traduzione letterale in
italiano significherebbe ambasciatore
delle formiche quindi l'arte l'abbiamo
presa l'abbiamo messa molto da parte new
game parla veneti che sono ambasciatori
delle liste informi che il loro destino
e nella mia mano cioè perché io faccio
l'ambasciatrice niente io mi sono fatto
il cosplay di una formica e ci ho messo
al posto del mio dito la forma di una
formica ha giustamente capito quindi io
mi fingo ambasciata sono un essere umano
oh mio dio uno straniero molto alto ma
baffo veramente grosso
e l'ambasciatore le formiche hunt bassa
dr è difficile da tradurre i giochi di
parole inglesi quando non parli inglese
soprattutto se parli in inglese a
livello di renzi sci allora riuscire a
trascinare il dito non è proprio il
massimo prof
va bene l'altro se formiche c'è nel
senso allora io non ho mai visto una
formica grossa quanto un mio dito cioè
mi farebbe veramente schifo bryant
passador vorrei non ho capito cosa mi ha
chiesto parte che la formica come fa a
chiedermi le cose però la mia casa è
bloccata ci penso io ci penso io è tutto
tuo zio tutto tuo
aspetta che code monia prego prego
benedetta sia la reggina va bene dietro
che lavorano prendono i pezzi di mela
salve salve ambasciatore parte ict gate
switching cerimoni ok non ho capito cosa
mi ha detto però io devo fare le cose
perché mi devo aprire la porta si posso
benissimo scavalcarlo il muro però
rispondiamo a questa domanda
apriti porta non apre niente sono un
ambasciatore per finta non sono capace
senti migliaia in a mano per favore se
non solo un essere umano
porca vacca ho mentito non c'è una
cerimonia ma come ho sfondato il muro
un'entrata fantastica ho capito cosa mi
hai detto dopo però sei simpatico ti do
un sacco di d d d aiutano distruggendo
le case no poverine dov'è il mio
cappello non posso svolgere il mio
lavoro senza te lo prendo gli aspetta
che sto sradicando dei tetti eccolo qua
tieni tiene amica mia ti ho sfondato
casa ma il cappello ce l'hai
madonna non li capisco cioè io già non
capisco invece figurati deformi cosa
fanno i soldati hanno iniziato una
terribile guerra qualcuno dovrebbe
buttare giù i loro cappelli faccio io
faccio io basta litigare
fate l'amore schifo di gioco ma no non
schiacciata una scusa finisce il gioco
se schiaccia formica non ci credo come
va bene a venelli li tolgo io non
schiacciano schiacciare che fai male non
schiacciare le formiche 1 via no ma rava
è difficilissimo cavolo c'è veramente
della del dl della skill in questo gioco
altro che fornai forte nel gioco del
2018 ragazzi cambiate un po idea perché
ci sono giochi che richiedono molta pisq
il parco demonia è difficile non
schiacciare le persone c'è le formiche
le queste tipe fanno veramente vomitare
le formiche in formato gigante comunque
non volevo dirvelo
piano piano molto bene benedetto sia
qualcosa o qualcuno
ok ambassador e ambasciatore la reggina
antonietta aspetta antoniette va bene
grazie amiche permesso a qua non ho
capito assolutamente niente però ti
benedico permesso permesso salve signora
reggina e lei
salve amica weber incontrato ambasciata
bue e milanese origine cioè vega beh
incontrada lascia l'era della pace
è stato un combattimento di farmi
leggere già difficile sono pronta a
mamma mary prince sposa la principessa
anastasia e corona la come tua reggina
[Musica]
[Applauso]
scusa è che mi fanno schifo le formiche
vabbè incoroniamo la figlia della regina
si rincorrono tua sorella la prossima
volta
sì sì ho capito ma la grana ti schiaccio
anche la famiglia perché parlano non
dovete parlare due fatemi giocare sposa
la principessa una sala della colonna
come tua reggina va bene allora
incoroniamo la difficile già tenere la
corona figuriamoci cavalca quanto
difficile maya che giochetti in cover it
in confronto era tutorial e nei ragazzi
la cosa più bella di questo gioco che
non l'ho pagato niente
capisco il perché allora ci calmiamo non
riesco a mente alloggio dei problemi o
metti la metti la per corte veramente ti
prego fa infine quest'agonia non ci
riesco non si fa ed ai e la st corona
maledetta che ha piano piano che ancora
un po dai fai ti prego mi sembra di
vedere un coso del migliora
l'esploratrice dove era però no qui io
mi oppongo chi è questo
antonio salutando esterno i membri
ricordo ancora le cicatrici della guerra
la distruzione la distruzione
dell'ambasciatore che si è abbattuto su
una società antonio se il lato la scorsa
settimana un duello è quindi lo avremo a
duellare con antonio sono senti antonio
tutto rispetto che ho per te andò senza
me no va bene hai voluto tu sei proprio
sicuro quello che volevo fare
vabbè double chi devo ridargli la corona
un'ora e mezza ci ho messo prima antonio
maledetto che vale quanto è difficile
con antonio pure chi di voi si chiama
antonio è vi odio antonio perché hunt
vuol dire formica antonio vacca gare va
a e verona si era intensa perché la
principessa si chiama anta stasia non
anastasi
non è la cosa film senza anta stasia
belongs ha chiesto sposando la reggina
capito quindi antonio syngas ed è bravo
antonio a 2
va bene antonio via niente posso
schiacciare solo antonio ed ho vinto io
la pace è stata non capisco cosa stai
dicendo
e quindi andiamo a ringraziare antonio
la nuova famiglia regale reale antonia
il mio lavoro mi rende veramente
orgoglioso di me stesso ogni giorno di
più
cosa non ha giocato nella mia vita cosa
dico sexy perché 39 va bene io l'ho
pagato questo gioco grazie a dio
colpa di antonio diciamocela tutta colpa
di ragazzi basta io non so che dire sono
la soddisfazione ciò nel corpo io grazie
di youtube per darmi spazio per poter
esterne e allora sapete qual è il
problema che se non ci fosse mai stato
youtube nel mondo no io avrei giocato
sta roba da solo ok
almeno così posso condividere le mine i
disagi con 5 milioni di persone che sono
tante quindi sono contento che mi
accompagnate nel disagio
iscrivetevi al canale ragazzi volume
liberamente e fate di questo regalo a
consigliate questo video a tutti gli
antonio che esistono vi prego per i
ragazzi prova al solito servizio vi è
piaciuto lasciato commento mi piace
anche re vari antonio che schiaccerete
col dito ogni mi piace un antonio in più
chiedetevi al canale e noi come sempre
ci vediamo l'anno prossimo visto ragazzi
[Musica]